merci guillaume depardieu
là ça se passait mieux que la dernière
fois que tu es venu là pour marché non
j'arrive à escalader un petit peu
commence à prendre l'habitude alors
guillaume depardieu acteur de cinéma
tous les matins du monde cible émouvante
quand les apprentis césar du meilleur
espoir pola x mart peau d'ange aime ton
père donc régulièrement à l'affiché au
cinéma mais aussi souvent guillaume
depardieu à la une des médias prison
ferme pour revendre d'héroïne en 1993
accident de moto en 1995 amputation de
la jambe en 2003 puis altercation à
trouville avec un pistolet à grenaille
neuf mois avec sursis 5000 euros
d'amendé
voilà donc vous êtes un garçon à la fois
qu'on retrouve sur les avances des films
et à la une est à la une des médias et
c'est pas fini puisque vous publié chez
plon un livre d'entretiens réalisés avec
marc olivier fogiel sont amis depuis
qu'il est dimanche soir c'est plus mon
ami quand les métiers de l'ange 20 jours
après et puis tout va bien il va te
réconcilier a les clefs sur ce plateau
très volontiers donc un livre qui va
faire grand bruit et qui s'appelle tout
donné
alors guillaume depuis la publication
des bonnes feuilles de ce livre dans
paris match tout le monde en parle c'est
le cas de le dire
et d'ailleurs la première mise en place
chez les libraires a été mercredi
dernier de 80 mille exemplaires alors au
départ c'est muriel bel air qui est
éditeur chez chez plon qui lie un
portrait de vous dans l qui vous appelle
et qui vous dit une vraie histoire
racontée et vous dites vous tombez bien
j'ai envie d'écrire
donc voilà donc muriel bel air pour
accoucher de ce témoignage
contact marc olivier fogiel avec qui
vous êtes ami depuis 1997
et donc c'est marco qui vous a accouché
alors au niveau de la méthode de travail
avant de passer au contenu du livre lui
dis tous les jours entre septembre et
décembre 2003 j'étais chez guillaume à
bougival tête bêche sur son lit avec un
magnéto en marche pendant trois heures
par jour
mettez-vous dans le même dans le même
journal vous dites qu'en fait vous avez
enregistré huit entretiens avec lui
c'est quoi alors il ya eu 80 retrait un
entretien d'une heure en fait ouais
et puis non mais ça c'est beau être le
journaliste qu'à lui il s'est trompé
ouais ouais la vérité c'est ça si vous
étés entretien d'une heure avec vais
peut-être belge sur le lit thierry bien
alors on va y aller un sont montés de
bêche
alors le livre commence à votre
naissance vous dites je ne suis pas les
normales ma mère a pris un médicament le
distilbène qui a été ensuite interdit à
cause de ses effets secondaires il 300
cas de deux jeunes filles qui sont nés
stérile et vous vous avez des
malformations corporelle dites vous des
eaux en plus des trucs comme ça va des
zones plus un cerveau en moins rex
bizarre et où des zones plus sombres à 1
et on nous a enlevé ses oh non non parce
que c'était pas sauf si je me cassais
sur la terre ferme
non mais c'était pas c'est pas grave et
le sexe l'opération du sexe ça c'est
plus marquant quand même si tous à la
puberté quand ça commence à bien frais
tier 1
déjà tout petit vous vous sentez
différentes voilà c'est ça tout ça mais
c'est ma classe je crois qu'un appel est
ma confiance lui ces bons mètres oui
mais il n'a pas sonné il a vibré
il a vibré ok ça y est on continue c'est
chiant avec 5
donc tout petit déjà vous sentez très
différent des autres ça vous remet en
marche finalement c'est ouais opérations
non puis tu te retrouves à l'hôpital
j'ai lu turin les cours ouais je sais ce
que tu aimes écoutes je vais pas te le
dit pas mais voilà alors vous parlez
aussi de vos rapports avec votre père
vous dites les rapports avec mon père
sont pas normaux non plus il travaillait
tout le temps je ne voyais jamais il
n'était pas compatissant de ce que vous
viviez à l'école sert qu'à l'école on
vous emmerdez à cause des valseuses à
cause d'un certain nombre de films que
votre père l'effet est en fait jamais il
vous a dit c'est pas grave
laisse tomber guillaume c'est des
connards ils n'étaient pas compatissant
non mais ce même pas ça d'être
compatissant ou pas c'était je ne sais
pas moi j'avais pas ne savais pas
comment réagir vis à vis a donc
généralement bon ça donnait des soucis
quand je me battais tout le temps vous
dites mon père il m'a eu trop tôt pensez
que c'est celui qui dit ce qu'il veut
mais je confirme
ouais gérard depardieu en plus il veut
pas trop vous aider parce qu'il ait pas
beaucoup et à l'école non plus donc je
suis touché ouais et alors vers 13-14
ans pour commencer a pu rien [ __ ] pour
commencer à fumer du shit est ce qui
fait de la colle donc c'est quand même
assez jeune vous trouvez vous dit
j'étais devenu quasiment autistes oui
parce que je n'aimais pas du tout le
monde qui m'entoure est oui c'est un peu
ennuyeux au mieux donc me réfugiais
surtout dans la musique vous écoutiez
quoi de tout
beaucoup de banques restait l'époque
c'était dans le hip hop et lui vous
preniez des dernier train pour paris
vous allez à paris vous marcher dans les
rues pendant toute la nuit le matin vous
preniez le premier train pour rentrer à
bougival faisait quoi l'année je
déambulais un peu dans pareil quand je
le promets je m'inventais des identités
jamais les barges été soit fils de
notaire sophys de militaires soient des
trucs bizarres enfin des trucs comme ça
mais j'ai quoi j'avais le privilège de
dole anonymat donc c'est comme ça en
fait que je me suis d'abord j'ai compris
que l'on pouvait avec un peu de
persuasion et en deviner tout le monde
c'est assez intéressant et puis ça m'a
permis de découvrir plein d'univers
différents
didier jamet que vous étiez le fils du
jardin j'avais maintenant sinon c'était
très drôle à 16 ans vous décidez comme
ça un jour sur un coup de tête de
devenir mercenaires de partir en afrique
larmes au point pour contrôler les
ressources pétrolières et minières et
[ __ ] l'occident dans la merde ça
c'était une une grande idée que vous
aviez ouais je suis vraiment prêt à
partir mais bien sûr on sait que c'est
une petite barbe de trotskisme
c'est pour le faire la révolution
mondiale non c'est pour support un film
ça s'est beaucoup mieux beaucoup plus
vénal ça c'était une semaine voulu être
mercenaires et puis la semaine d'après
vous écoutez le requiem de mozart vous
fondant en larmes et vous dites c'est ça
que je veux être ce mozart ouais c'est
un peu le résumé comme ça ça fait un peu
mais c'est ça c'est ça
non en fait je voulais vraiment me
barrer pour quelque chose qui valait le
coup est finalement bon j'ai eu la
chance de l'écouter mozart ouais parce
que sinon je me barre et c'est
exactement ici
non c'est même une certaine manière
c'est la donner
un sens au fait le choix ici en occident
je me suis dit on peut on peut arriver
aux mêmes choses le but mais en
construisant et pas en détruisant voilà
alors à l'époque vous êtes 20 d'argent
vient de talent à revendre votre père
non non vous êtes gigolo je sais le
grand recours si maintenant j'étais si
c'est pas pour pas que pour l'argent
c'est par exemple une première curiosité
bien sûr vous êtes gigolo pour pour
femmes pour un homme
vous commencez avec des femmes mûres
j'aimais bien les fameux mur est donc là
c'était pas tellement un pénible
non non c'était plutôt mais signe un
squeeze c'était rigolo de luxe j'avais
le choix chez les clients ouais ouais
c'est toujours plus agréable et bien que
les mecs aussi sérieux vous raconter le
premier mec
le premier ouais 14 ans ouais mais s'est
pas passé grand-chose la première fois
heureusement non juste préliminaire
ouais et après c'était plus sérieux
c'est arrivé 1 vous avez appris quoi
dans cette expérience
ben jamais tourné le dos ces métiers des
douches non non j'ai appris mais j'ai
appris plein de choses j'ai appris que
c'était dans la tête aussi les choses
commencent à se rallier
heureusement quand vous retrouvez en
tourner la première fois il ya un caïd
qui vous protège et vous échapper à aux
sévices sexuels habituel des prisons ou
enfin aux sévices sexuels non je pense
pas que que j'étais une proie
ainsi niveau là et non j'ai échappé
surtout au lynchage mais ouais pendant
la première fois que j'allais en taule
c'est pas encore pour usage de
stupéfiants sous pour braquage de weston
et 2 mais c'était l'époque la venue de
jun ouais ouais ça va encore ouais enfin
bon
et puis on a ce qu'on m'aide et wesson
avec une doudoune je n'ai pas évolué
d'un goodwill un débit vers 18 ans vous
commencé à mettre le nez dans la poudre
seul a duré six ans vite j'ai perdu six
ans de ma vie là dedans
ouais mais je pense que nous a rien
apporté du tout si mais ça m'a apporté
justement de mais rétrospectivement
parce que je m'en suis sorti mais parce
que je suis costaud quand même
non mais j'en connais tous mes potes de
l'époque sont pas sortis ils sont soit d
une fouille choix ils sont morts soit
ils ont fait aujourd'hui ensemble
en fait le mec qui vous a branché dans
la drogue dans la poudre dans l'héroïne
c'est le prof de solfège
oui le contrepoint et d'harmonie vous
recueillez un jour chez vous parce que
son père était mort et un jour vous le
voyez en train de se faire un fixe dans
la salle de bain et vous essayez quoi
ouais enfin j'avais ici un petit peu
avant je faisais un remplacement
je vais avoir 16 ans quand j'ai essayé
mais c'était juste un trait d'héroïne 1
à 5 ans mais jamais rien fait alors là
évidemment quand on prend de l'héroïne
au début c'est vachement bien on croit
que tous les problèmes sont réglés même
c'est après comme on l'est toujours au
début on en prend pour être bien puis
après peut pas être humain pas qu'après
on court après alors vous essayez tout
voir ici non seulement l'héroïne mais
aussi l'héroïne mélangé à de la cocaïne
ce qu'on appelle speedball le speedball
ensuite vous avez pris du crack vous
ayez pas peur de vomir et le cerveau non
non j'ai lu quelque part qu'on utilisait
on utilisait toute façon juste un
dixième
c'est un peu mon neurone toute une
existence est donc bon non mais je
n'avais pas une approche très
quantitative des choses c'était plutôt
c'est plutôt fallait tout essayer
ouais et puis un jour en revenant de
hollande ou par départir pour le ski
quand le fameux prof de solfège qui vous
a initiés vous appelle il me dit je suis
mal je suis mal viennent des panais
j'étais parti pour décrocher enfin bon
si vous appelle je suis mal viens viens
viens bien m'aider à faire les choses
bien dépanner la caisse c'est un truc
que je comptais pour pas être prendre
pour pat mal le prendre le lendemain
matin
ouais et dont j'ai eu passé et puis là
j'ai vu le flag ouais vraiment comme ça
vous faites serré vous finissez donc
évidemment en prison alors en prison me
dit kapaya pas de drogue évidemment il
n'ya pas d'héroïne mais il ya la fiole
c'est quoi la fiole mais c'est ce qu'on
donne dans toutes les prisons en france
et une bonne ça pour les mecs parce
qu'ils sont il ya beaucoup de toxico
quand même les joies des violences ou
les vols quels qu'ils soient enfin de la
rapine tout ça c'est vraiment
l'essentiel des chantiers en prison à 70
% c'est lié au manque à ma drogue
donc on leur donne pour les calmer pour
patty z'hurlants toute la nuit comme ici
mon nom qu'on leur donne des 38 10 ans
des opiacés des enfants les shoots quoi
on avait prévu oui mais un jour un jour
au dos et puis après toute façon moi
j'étais mariée que je voulais m'arrêter
ça tombait bien les ardennes façon je
voulais venir rappelle balladur pour
essayer de vous faire sortir de là en
fait vous lui en voulez parce que moi
j'ai trouvé que c'est quand même trop
facile d'être le fils de jr de pinon
mais si moi je sais pas du tout comment
jamais été comme ça et je serai jamais
comme ça non j'étais condamné j'estime
injustement
il en voulait dire un exemple je crois
c'est tel changement de politique tu
vois c'était un peu la droite qui y
vivent mais il fallait bien montrer que
attention maintenant les jeunes ça
rigole plus et donc bah là maintenant on
continue à dérouler même tapis quoi donc
c'est assez intéressant de voir que ça
ne sert strictement à rien
il met pas les gens qui sont malades en
prison ça ridicule mais voulue à votre
père d'avoir essayé d'intervenir auprès
de la base il à dire vous auriez préféré
finalement qu'il voulait cela pour
empêcher un peu c'est vrai que qu'ils
soient pas là du tout qu'ils ne viennent
pas en plus mais discrédité
moi j'ai à dire je voulais faire ma
peine jusqu'au bout et yappa problème là
dessus je viens moi je fais ma peine
c'est le même si j'estime que j'ai rien
à [ __ ] là-dedans justement c'est
motivant c'est très motivant et je vous
faisiez vous c'était une certaine
rédemption par là par la punition ne
rompt pas du tout d'un coup la la dumont
garde nous avoir ce genre de pensées
l'agile et aux chrétiens non merci non
non non c'est plutôt devoir de mettre
les choses à plat avec l'esprit clair et
de voir dans quelle société j'évolue et
donc à partir de là c'est très bien je
sais que je suis malade je sais
maintenant que on prend les mêmes comme
ça qu'on a fait ça je sais avoir les
idées claires
j'étais arrêté six ans plus tard vous
êtes arrêté comment tout seul sans rien
non fort méthadone comme ça ouais solide
dure voilà et puis ensuite vous raconter
dans le bouquin votre amputation ensuite
à cette maladie nosocomiale
on vous propose soit d'avoir la jambe
raide toute votre vie soit vous faire
amputer ça fait un bon petit parallèle
il va les mecs qui sont malades dont les
fonds ont tous les mecs qui vont les
autorisons [ __ ] j'ai testé pour vous
vous avez préféré être amputé plutôt que
voilà j'aimerai faisable un feu
intenable et en faisant jouer plus rien
faire non mais il y en a même qui m'ont
dit elle quand même attiré bien des
merlettes n'a pas fait comme tout le
monde mais il y en a qui arrivent dire
ça les yeux dans les yeux en pensant
vraiment que c'est vrai que j'ai fait
exprès pour faire bien dans le
curriculum alors votre père vous appelle
donc après cette amputation et vous
appelle à l'hôpital il vous dit ça va
comment vous dites ça très bien espèce
de sarcasmes ça va très bien j'ai fait
un drôle de rêve papa j'étais entouré
ski tout nu qui me cissé le moignon j'ai
vu toutes ses formes vraiment
il avait des limites au sens de l'humour
me dit mon père je l'aimais je le
déteste pour les mêmes raisons son
impuissance
non mais c'est toujours pareil toute
façon les gens les aiment quand on les
aime vraiment si vous les a remerciés
pour leurs défauts il n'a pas été assez
dur avec vous pensez franchement ouais
non je joue non mais c'est une manière
douce qui est autrement plus dur aussi
de dire à quelqu'un la démerde toi tu
vas voir à la dure quoi moi je trouve
que ça m'a amené vers une liberté qui
est vrai c'est voilà c'est vrai ça je
dois le concéder je trouve que c'est
intéressant de dire à quelqu'un démerde
toi toute façon tu vas être bien être
obligé un jour te démerder donc mais
c'était peut-être un peu tôt est-ce que
vous lui en voulez de ne pas vous avoir
donné un exemple parce que vous dites
dans le bouquin mon père s'est fait ce
que je dis ne fais pas ce que je fais
ouais vous trouvez qu'il manque
d'intégrité et d'éthique c'est à dire
que vous pensez que finalement il que
non mais quand on quand on a des trucs à
soi faut le cacher vraiment quoi il faut
pas que ça se voit sur les ferries qui
soient plus discrets pour vous donner un
exemple plus plus droit bah oui je suis
pas ton café à un prêt ne pas pas venir
en se posant en présentant garant de la
justice quelle qu'elle soit mais après
moi après ce que j'ai vu je vois un
flipper c'est pas le top crédibilité
ouais vous découvrez battre oui comme
tous les gens de sa génération vous
découvrez kiseka mais qui valut à des
partouzes voilà comme ça non mais ça
c'est bien après ouais moi j'étais déjà
barré depuis longtemps j'étais déjà un
homme à tête c'était vous avez dix ans
j'étais déjà dans mon univers on avait
pu m'accrocher
découvrez même qu'il a une fille avec
karine silla demi soeur il n'a pas osé
vous en parlez vous la prenez le gélat
prigent de sa naissance un parce que
karine silla appelez votre père devant
vous ouais pour dire que tout s'était
bien passé nous apprenez sa vie privée
par la presse en fait ouais mais
aujourd'hui aussi la première dont vous
l'avez appris en lisant pas en rajouter
un peu a franchi puisque maintenant
j'essaie voir un peu les rapports
je trouve ça bien
c'est bien qu'ils soient avec cette
famille ouais ouais préférez les fans
gardent encore le bouquet j'ai rien dit
alors parler de votre mère aussi
lisabeth depardieu vous dites qu'ils
sont en instance de divorce depuis 14
ans parce qu'il veut pas lâcher sur le
plan au pognon quant au web quel
problème du milliardaire votre perdre
franchement c'est assez opaque
ouais je sais pas ce que vous dites
quand je t'ai pim donnez pas d'argent ma
mère il veut pas divorcer parce qu'il
veut pas lâcher non mais quand
j'utilisais l'argent principes
d'éducation ma main et je trouve ça très
bienveillant c'est à dire que moi
j'avais pas plus d'argent que meilleur
ami est bon comme c'était une famille
nombreuse quatre enfants des milieux bon
ouais un pauvre
donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien mais
non mais mon père il n'est pas du tout
pas généraux et c'est pas vrai faux pas
comprendre ça non plus et c'est
quelqu'un qui a du mal à filer une pièce
par contre peu de films brics mme way
donc moi j'ai pas j'ai pas tendance à
demander facilement une brique vous avez
divorce et c'était réglé avec élise n'ai
pas attendu 14 ans quoi ouais on est on
est on est en train de faire ouais
heureusement que les louise quand même
non oui alors quand votre père a lu le
bouquin il nous a dit que certains
passages étaient pas bien qu'ils étaient
non mais parce qu'il n'avait pas lu il
se connaît comment il je suis comme
quand il dit je lis les scénarios il
avait su ite trois trucs ici vous un
dialogue intéressant et le prend s'il
voit un truc et après le lit mais bon là
il avait juste parcouru trois feuillets
y dit oui en france il m'appelait juste
pour me dire qu'il trouvait ça un
pudique
ouais et vous avez dit que vous le
trouviez indécent ouais il à lui
maintenant je pense vous est pas une
nouvelle
non ils vous répondent en dans gala vous
l'avais dit à ben oui j'ai eu des
nouvelles par greg c'est terrible ce
qu'il dit parce que il y en at il dit si
ça l'aide décrire ce bouquin tant mieux
pour lui si ça vous attendez comme
attitude vous voyez attendait quelque
chose de violent
franchement je m'en fous ça me m'empêche
pas de dormir c'est pas ça qui me fait
lever le matin
ouais maintenant vous avez fait ce
bouquin vous sentez libéré de quelque
chose
wesh sens en tout cas on ne posera plus
les mêmes questions à chaque fois que
j'aimerais faire la promo pour un truc
que j'ai fait que j'étais bien et qui
mérite plus largement de la tension
plutôt que sur ma famille ou quoi que ce
soit comme ça j'ai fait aussi pour ça
que j'ai trouvé bien mon intérêt là
dedans donc fait un peu chier avec ma
famille à mes blagues et dans les ronces
et je trouve ça infernal c'est perrine
ça va les gens vont se lasser attention
gérard sa dernière fois vous en parler
là alors ouais enfin bien marquer le
coup quand même à la dernière fois c'est
énorme si vous après vous avez pas être
vos films oui je vais les faire surtout